[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mitglied
der jury ihnen allen frohe weihnachten
und willkommen an heilig abend an dem
sich die welt natürlich auch weiter
dreht wir versorgen sie in der nächsten
viertelstunde mit den wichtigsten
informationen und hier sind einige
unserer themen
weihnachten im krisenmodus gedämpfte
freude an heiligabend strengere krone
regeln drücken fielen auf die stimmen
weihnachtsbotschaft als zeichen der
hoffnung die großen kirchen in
deutschland rufen zur zusammenhalt und
mehr menschlichkeit auf
und stille nach dem bethlehem auch in
diesem jahr fehlen bei der feierlichen
prozession die pilger im heiligen land
ja kein einfaches fest wegen der sich
rasant verbreitenden omikron variante
treten schärfere corona maßnahmen zwar
fast überall erst ab dem 28 dezember in
kraft einige bundesländer haben
allerdings schon vorgelegt in hamburg
zum beispiel gelten schon ab heute
strenge regeln das ganz große
familienfest fällt also wieder aus
maximal zehn personen geimpft oder
genießen dürfen sich treffen und dazu
kommt eine sperrstunde für die
gastronomie und ein tanzverbot über
weihnachten im party-modus ralf
zimmermann von sieff hat das hamburg mal
wieder vorprescht mit der verschärfung
von kontakt beschränkungen die meisten
versuchen es offensichtlich gelassen zu
nehmen vielleicht auch mit ein wenig
weihnachtlicher sehnsucht nach harmonie
und persönlichem frieden man hat in der
vergangenheit gesehen dass ja dass die
zahlen massiv hochgehen und deswegen ist
es präventiv glaube ich ganz gut
natürlich schade aber sagen wir ein
anderes machen wir können ja nicht
ändern ich versuche es über die
feiertage ein bisschen abzuschalten und
zu sagen das ist jetzt so wie es dann
muss man das auch so wahrnehmen
abschalten oft wohl auch verdrängen für
viele betroffene ist es aber auch
wichtig in ihrer seelischen not halt zu
finden miteinander reden unterstützung
anbieten ist wichtig ist menschlich ist
gerade das was wir vielleicht auch um
die feiertage besonders brauchen und
wieder trifft ist die klub und freizeit
szene junger menschen tanz lustbarkeiten
wie es altmodisch im amtsdeutsch heißt
sind ab heute wieder verbotene in
hamburg und nächste woche dann im ganzen
land die branche ein erneuter
zukunftsangst
die ganzen überbrückungshilfen sind
schön aber das ist das ist nur das was
das überleben gerade so maximal reicht
aber wir brauchen wirklich ein
wiederaufbauprogramm und jan eine
bessere finanzielle absicherung für ein
fach personal
geimpft wurde auch in hamburg heute noch
selbst in staatlichen einrichtungen auch
wenn man hier besorgt auf den
möglicherweise drohenden impfstoffmangel
im neuen jahr schaut die kontakt
beschränkungen sollen durch behörden und
polizei überwacht werden bis zu zehn
personen geimpft oder genießen wir
konzentrieren uns auf den öffentlichen
raum das was wir nicht machen werden ist
wir werden nicht von haus zu haus gehen
in die fenster der menschen schauen und
zählen wie viele menschen unter dem
tannenbaum sitzen ein zweites
weihnachtsfest ganz im zeichen des
corona virus und in der ungewissheit
nicht nur in hamburg ob es reichen wird
was jetzt beschlossen ist
also kontakt beschränkungen das große
und clubs dicht und schärfere corona
regeln bald in allen bundesländern was
ab wann wo gilt einen überblick dazu bei
uns auf der zdf heute beziehungsweise in
unserer app
omikron hat viele kalt erwischt
offiziell hat das robert-koch-institut
bis jetzt rund
3200 fälle registriert die dunkelziffer
dürfte um ein vielfaches höher liegen
weil nicht alle positiven corona fälle
auch auf virus mutationen untersucht
werden dazu alexandra vacano
sicher ist sicher schnell noch mal
testen vor dem weihnachtsfest wie heute
hier in neumarkt in der oberpfalz denn
omikron holt auf inzwischen ist die
korona variante in allen 16
bundesländern angekommen am stärksten
betroffen nordrhein westfalen gefolgt
von bayern und hamburg in deutschland
wird nur ein kleiner teil der positiven
proben auf omikron hin getestet die
häufigsten symptome laut lka schnupfen
husten halsschmerzen also eher milde
verläufe bei infizierten die vollständig
geimpft oder gemustert sind soviel ist
bislang klar und klar dagegen die
datenlage ergo-chef wieder hatte
vorgewarnt während der feiertage und zum
jahreswechsel sei mit einer geringeren
test und melde aktivität zu rechnen der
chef des weltärztebund kritisiert die
lückenhafte erfassung es ist mir
vollkommen unverständlich warum wir nach
wie vor an jedem wochenende eine unklare
datenlage haben wie auch an den
feiertagen es könnte zu vielen falschen
interpretationen führen so die warnung
doch die gesundheitsämter würden schon
lange über dem limit arbeiten jetzt
fehle das personal so die vorsitzende
der ärztinnen und ärzte des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes
eine flächendeckende nachverfolgung
findet im moment gar nicht mehr statt
derweil wird weiter geimpft und geimpft
inzwischen haben 29,8 millionen menschen
ihre auffrischungsimpfung erhalten
bundespräsident steinmeier hat zu
solidarität in der korona pandemie
aufgerufen nach zwei jahren machte sich
frust breit und auch offene aggression
sagte steinmeier in seiner
weihnachtsansprache in einer demokratie
müssten nicht alle einer meinung sein
doch müsse man sich auch nach der
pandemie noch in die augen schauen
können die ganze weihnachtsansprache
zeigt das zdf morgen um 19 uhr 8 direkt
nach der heute sendung auch die großen
kirchen stellen corona in den
mittelpunkt ihrer weihnachtsbotschaften
sie sprechen sich für mehr
rücksichtnahme in der pandemie und
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt aus zum
zweiten mal feiern christen das fest von
jesu geburt unter corona bedingungen
gottesdienste können nur eingeschränkt
stattfinden
andrea meuser
es ist ein ruhiger gottesdienst zu dem
georg bätzing vorsitzender der deutschen
bischofskonferenz in die privatkapelle
des limburger bischofs hauses einlädt
keine gläubigen ein streamen internet
corona bestimmt die form aber auch wenn
die pandemie vieles verändert eines
bleibe immer gleich betonte bischof
weihnachten ist für christen ein fest
der freude
diese nacht ist von einem besonderen
geheimnis geprägt denn in dieser nacht
wurde gott ein bruder für uns menschen
in dieser nacht ist er gekommen um uns
zu vergewissern
ich lasse dich nicht allein
miteinander begegnung und gemeinsamkeit
dafür steht am heutigen abend auch die
evangelische zionskirche in bielefeld
weil das für mich einfach weihnachten
ausmacht annette kurschus
ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen kirche
in deutschland stellt die korona
pandemie in den mittelpunkt ihrer
predigt sieht parallelen zwischen damals
und heute was sich in jener zeit begab
begibt sich wieder
heute erfahren wir es neu und auch nie
geahnte weise was es bedeutet der macht
bezahle ausgeliefert zu sein jeden tag
wie viele infizierte wie viele erkrankte
wie viele tote wie viele intensivbetten
wie viele beatmungsgeräte wie viele
impfdosen
es ist wieder ein weihnachten im
ausnahmezustand aber mit den
gottesdiensten des heutigen tages
bekennen evangelische und katholische
christen ihren glauben mit der geburt
jesu kam hoffnung und licht in die welt
[Musik]
jetzt dorthin wo alles begonnen haben
soll nach bethlehem dem ort den christen
als geburtsort jesu christi verehren
normalerweise zu weihnachten
pilgerstätte für menschen aus aller welt
aber corona bremst die ganz großen
feierlichkeiten jetzt zum zweiten mal
aus und das bedeutet für die
einheimischen auch dass die einnahmen
fehlen wir uns anders zeigt
frühe morgen im westjordanland in der
zeit vor corona würden schon jetzt
hunderte touristen durch die straßen von
bethlehem streifen an diesem morgen
lehre dass marco zeit an ihrem laden
heute öffnet hat mehr mit routine zu tun
als mit umsatz touristen kommen schon
seit wochen keine mehr
das geschäftsleben ist völlig zerstört
und auch das gesellschaftliche leben ist
völlig zusammengebrochen
früher verdiente sie 800 euro im monat
nun sind es kaum noch 140 und immer
wieder muss die 68-jährige den laden
ganz schließen die arbeitslosigkeit in
bethlehem ist mit 25 prozent die höchste
im westjordanland
es verbrennt mein herz neulich habe ich
einen mutter um geld gebeten um essen
für ihre kinder zu kaufen
wir sind dann ein schwierigen punkt
angelangt
die stimmung will sich die familie aber
nicht verderben lassen weihnachts
routine trotz corona auch am
krippenplatz der jährliche einzug des
patriarchen zur geburtskirche ein
volksfest
normalerweise würden hier an der
geburtsgrotte wo jesus geboren sein soll
hunderte schlange stehen nun bleibt es
bei ein paar wenigen besuchern aus der
umgebung es ist nicht schön diese lehre
macht mir angst
bei familie zeiten sind die
vorbereitungen für den abend
mittlerweile fast abgeschlossen nur ob
oma marco den wunsch ihrer enkel auch
erfüllen kann bleibt ungewiss
ich hoffe es schneit dieses jahr
ja einen schneemann
während drinnen die bescherung
stattfindet wird dieser heiligabend
draußen zu einer besonders stillen nacht
nach griechenland jetzt dort ist vor der
küste ein flüchtlingsboot gesunken
mindestens elf menschen kamen dabei ums
leben das boot war nordwestlich von
kreta auf grund gelaufen 90 menschen
konnten sich auf eine kleine insel
retten die küstenwache brachte sie in
sicherheit
erst am mittwoch war ein flüchtlingsboot
vor der griechischen küste gesunken
mindestens drei menschen starben
dutzende werden noch vermisst
schnee und eisige temperaturen
sehnen sich viele zu weihnachten herbei
aber im straßenverkehr ist das natürlich
kein vergnügen es kam zu diversen teils
schweren verkehrsunfällen besonders
betroffen der norden bei anhaltendem
schneefall und glatten straßen kamen
autos ins rutschen und von der fahrbahn
ab wie hier bei rostock und auch bei der
bahn kam es zu zugausfällen und
verspätungen
schenkende sind ja häufig auch
beschenkte zumindest ist das heute abend
an heiligabend der fall und wie
beziehungsweise wann ein geschenk
besorgt wird das lässt vielleicht grob
in zwei lager einteilen es gibt jene die
früh und rechtzeitig alle präsente
beisammen haben und die die auf den
allerletzten drücker noch ein last
minute geschenk organisieren wie zb in
hannover oliver deuker
hannover innenstadt am morgen bis 14 uhr
haben die meisten geschäfte geöffnet der
große andrang ist es nicht nur wer muss
ist unterwegs es ist der tag der
spätentschlossenen vielleicht der
verzweifelten auf der suche nach einem
oder sogar mehreren weihnachtsgeschenken
es fällt schon sehr auf das heute eine
männerdomäne unterwegs ist also sind da
doch die herren die immer wieder so ein
bisschen das glaube ich so vor sich her
schieben und sagen um was fehlt mir noch
ein und dann wird eben doch gern wieder
auf dem lieblingsduft zurückgegriffen
aber so alters technisch ist das
eigentlich von 20 bis open end ist jeder
heute bei unter ist sie diese spezies
für die weihnachten so ganz plötzlich so
ganz überraschend kommt und dass alle
jahre wieder brauchen sie den
nervenkitzel oder ist es die spontane
zündende idee für die last minute
einkauf wo drückt sich davor um
und
dann überlegt man sich ja bis x hab gar
nichts was das ist verrückt jedes jahr
aufs neue weil ich eigentlich
vorgestellt hatte aber es kam nicht und
jetzt stress einfach ein bisschen
schleifen lassen so hat man anderes zu
tun muss arbeiten und dann kommt das
gern mal ins vergessen sie sind eine der
letzten hoffnungen die paketboten für
die die vorweihnachtszeit massenhaft
überstunden heißt die auch heute die
letzten express pakete verteilen und
wartende kunden mit ihrer lieferung
beglücken hoffen wir dass auch sie
mittlerweile zu hause sind
komisch dass das mit den last minute
geschenken immer nur auf männer zutrifft
so mehr vom weihnachtswetter gibt's
gleich mit katja horneffer morgen
begrüßte hier an dieser stelle meine
kollegin jana park ist das gesamte heute
team wünscht ihnen und ihren liebsten
noch entspannte weihnachtstage bleiben
sie gelassen passen sie auf sich auf und
kommen sie gut rüber
[Musik]
fröhliche weihnachten heute nach
schneide zwischen sachsen und dem
saarland im süden fällt regen die
temperaturen sind ganz unterschiedlich
über den neuschnee flächen im nordosten
geht es auf minus 10 -12 grad runter am
oberrhein bleibt es mild mit 6 grad
diese temperaturgegensätze bleiben uns
auch morgen über tag erhalten im
nordosten bleibt es bei minus 4 bis 0
grad dauerhaft frostig im südwesten geht
es dagegen bis 10 grad drauf dort fällt
regen aber in diesem streifen vom
niederrhein bis zum sauerland fällt
schnee schneeregen oder gefährlicher
glatteisregen über norddeutschland
strahlt die sonne das ist perfektes
winterwetter das uns auch am zweiten
feiertag noch erhalten bleibt auch wenn
die grenze zwischen dem leuchtend blauen
und dem schmuddelig grauen himmel sich
ein bisschen verschied frohes fest